a pesar de la crisis energética que
azota Europa el espíritu navideño llega
a las calles en la famosa Avenida de los
campos elíseos prendieron millones de
luces algunos turistas justifican el
gasto
hay que tener algo de Alegría en la vida
y quiero decir mira cuánta gente hay
aquí nos ha unido a todos
Definitivamente creo que vale la pena
según la administración cambiaron los
horarios para ayudar a la política de
ahorro del gobierno y las luces son de
bajo consumo estos nuevos horarios son
una forma de mostrarnos solidarios de
ser ahorradores de ser sostenibles y
razonables y de respetar el medio
ambiente en bucarest inauguraron la
feria navideña en alcalde de la capital
rumana dice que a pesar de los malos
tiempos que atraviesa Europa la Navidad
es importante
no son los mejores tiempos que estamos
atravesando Y al menos para las
vacaciones de invierno debemos estar
contentos las denominadas medidas de
sobriedad en Europa están activas en un
momento en que el comercio trata de
atraer a los compradores con doctrinas
luminosas con la guerra en Ucrania
activa las sanciones a Rusia y los
problemas latentes con el suministro de
Vegas ruso por el norte 1 se espera una
fría de Navidad donde los hogares
pagarán un alto precio por la energía en
el invierno